greetings earthlings I've been summoned
here by the Nexus laser beam signal
which is in the form of a hand reaching
up out of the sea either waving or
drowning I'm not sure which only the
wonderful Nexus could have been tyst me
to come it is not easy to make the
interstellar journey but what are better
placed than Amsterdam for me to visit so
long a city of tolerance openness and
respect for all so I am very pleased to
be here among you though I admit that
many of your ways still seem bizarre to
me despite the extensive research I have
done on you I come from a planet in a
galaxy far far away and in another genre
the name of my planet is unpronounceable
by you since you like the necessary
vocal structures which led us to view
you for many millennia as lacking in
intelligent life but I have translated
this name very approximately as mashup
musics it seems to be a rule with you
that the names of alien planets must
contain letters
Zend Y and X then I have accommodated
this rule in my translation I note that
here within the mini planet of Nexus you
have developed a rudimentary
understanding of this rule as your own
name contains an X your sages tell me
that a Nexus is a connection linking two
or more things more or less like a
safety pin that it is the connected
group or series which confused me on our
planet everything is connected or that
it is this
and most important place of something
also confusing to me as on mashup six
each of us as the center and the
circumference is everywhere but I
understand that you have good intentions
my friends if I may call you that on
mashup six we have no enemies so we do
not need this word for friend but here
on earth I grasp you see the world in
alternates and contrasts good evil light
dark wet dry fun boring human rights
worker nasty race traitorous reeking
trash pile of garbage I am beginning to
get the him and hang of things I believe
I came here to discover the answer to
the question what are these human rights
of which you speak it is not a question
that makes any sense to us on mat
chopsticks since on our planet we have
no need for such things as specially
delineated rights all of us although we
are by no means identical to one another
in fact we are extremely various as to
appearances and hobbies all of us are
equal in the social and legal senses
unlike it sadly appears yourselves you
need these human rights items spelled
out for the simple reason that a lot of
you haven't got them we mash up sixty
ins have two questions that we'd like to
ask of anything is it true and is it
fair if it is not true that some people
are by nature and fair to others isn't
fair that they should be treated as if
they are after many millennia of
treating some people as by nature
inferior but nevertheless gradually
extending the franchise or the
participation in full citizenship from
Kings to Nobles from noble
two male landowners from landowners two
male inhabitants you human beings or
some of you finally got it into your
heads that human rights should be
universal organized and well-funded
forces are at work against these fragile
human rights it appears that there are
some among you who are bored with the
blandness of quasi democracies and wish
to resurrect the totalitarianism of the
20th century to this I would say beware
it may seem like a jolly idea at the
beginning what with all the marching and
cosplay and the feeling that you are
serving a fearless leader who will tell
you the truth unlike any of those in the
past but these things have never ended
well especially for the citizens do you
agree with the political muzzling of
climate science and toxicity research do
you deride evidence-based journalism and
evidence-based policies do you applaud
the smashing up of newspapers and the
beating up and murdering of journalists
do you shout hurray when the press is
called
pat chase tellin the enemy of the people
if so line up over here in the queue
marked dictatorship the line forms
either to the left or to the right but
as they say about dead people they all
end up in the same box not that we use
boxes as such on our planet our funeral
funeral ceremonies consist of but I will
leave that for another time let us just
say that a certain amount of mashup
Sixto Fergie is involved waste not want
not
none of us has ever exactly dead just
dispersed you have transhumanists we
have Trent's mash up six teens
to end on a note of hope mashup 60 ins
love notes of hope you are not living in
a totalitarian dictatorship now or yet
please avoid it
earthlings you need not go down the
divisive path of suspicion and hatred
you can instead identify as fellow human
beings and try to understand and face
your common human problems together and
you do have some large problems to solve
for instance unless you regulate the
temperature and chemical makeup of your
planet you will all be plastic
before long your oceans will die and
then you won't be able to breathe and it
will be goodbye Homo sapiens sapiens
will be sorry to see you go you have
some good points we do like Mozart but
we can save the scores and play the
music ourselves
now I must shed my disguise of elderly
short female person glow with an
incandescent light sprout multiple
pseudopod like extensions and shoot up
into the stratosphere bound for a planet
in a galaxy far far away and in another
genre earthlings
behave yourselves have fun when possible
avoid totalitarianism x' enjoy the cat
videos read up on human rights eat lots
of kale get rid of single-use plastic
farewell until we meet again
you
[Applause]